love having this guy on this is one of i
i've lost track of his appearances here
in person as well as on the phone
and he is co-hosting a one-hour concert
special with eve called play on
celebrating the power of music to make
change that's going to be on tuesday
december 15th
at 8 eastern time on cbs and cbs all
access
raising money for two long-standing
vital philanthropic organizations one
being the ncaa legal defense and
educational fund
and why hunger all collected through the
play on fund at sixdegrees.org
which is funded by our next guest kevin
bacon how are you sir
it was really fun to hear you guys
ripping before i got on here i
i always get a kick out of that well i
i do i i do read copy for a living and
hit music stings for a liv and i take
pride in that kevin you know i take
pride in my work you should
thank you you should my man it's good
it's good to know it's good to know your
strengths
you know yeah i can hit the post too if
i if i if i you know
ramp up for music i could hit a post too
you know i can do that
but it's the sting that really gets me
i'll be honest kevin listen
yeah i i think
we need these skills we need these
skills it's a dying art
thank you so walk me through um
walk me through this concert and how it
came about
and um and why you're doing it i'll give
you the floor sure
yeah sure um well there was a great
uh group of folks uh including john
varvatos
who were doing a uh yearly
charity live show at the beacon theater
in new york
called love rocks and i'd played there
with my band and i'd also been there
subsequent years
and they they got together and started
thinking about
during the pandemic about doing
something else for charities that would
be
on television with with live music and
john and our other partners are all big
fans of um
of of music and all kinds of music
and so we they asked me to come on board
and we started talking and this was i
think in march
about doing some kind of a show
we knew that we wanted to do something
around
hunger it was going to be really clear
looking at the
situation economically in the country
that that was going to become an issue
that was going to become more and more
important
and also social justice and
so we started to talk about what the
show could be
and you know at that point there were
people that were
doing some uh music shows a lot of them
were
uh i'm in my living room with an
acoustic guitar and and
uh it was incredibly uh heartwarming but
we wanted to have something
that was a little bit a little bit more
of a live
kind of uh feel all of us being
fans of live music and of of some of
these iconic venues that we ended up
focusing on and um it's been a long road
but
we put together a an amazing group of
artists uh pretty much across the boards
of uh musical genres i mean we have
hip-hop we've got rap we've got rock
we've got power punk we've got soul
music
we've got i mean the only thing reggae i
mean
the only thing i thought maybe we didn't
have was was uh
jazz and then i realized that john
batiste does this very jazzy solo during
a rendition of
people get ready um and and so i think
we're
if you like music i think it's going to
be a really exciting show yeah bon jovi
ll cool j machine gun kelly snoop sheryl
crow and more from places like the
troubadour here in l.a the apollo
theater in new york bluebird cafe in
nashville it's play on celebrating the
power of music
to make change tuesday december 15th
kevin bacon here
uh on the rich eisen show um which one
of these folks you know personally let's
drop names is bon jovi
it's bon jovi i do i do know john yeah
in fact john
he's the one he's the one yeah you
probably um
mind his stuff in terms of our era but
um
uh years ago john was doing a solo album
uh
called destination anywhere and uh he
was
shooting this kind of long-form video
it's almost like a little
mini movie and he asked me to to act on
it
and and i did and uh so so yeah we've
uh we've known each other for a long
time okay so which musicians you've ever
been around with the best acting chops
done
kevin which one do you think oh
crosstalk who's
oh listen uh well um
i think that uh will smith he he's
he's done some smacking in his life yes
jamie foxx
is another one uh just you know
incredible
you know uh harry connick jr
um john johnson some acting
i mean there's a little there's a lot of
them you know listen i play in a band so
i can't fault anybody for wanting to
cross over
you know to me that would just that
would just be setting me you know up for
a fall
i do think that and we may have talked
about this before is that
i think that most people i think most
people are more supportive
of musicians who want to act
than they are of actors who want to play
music and i think the reason is is
that most people look at actors and they
think that what we do is probably pretty
easy
you know it's kind of like listen you
know if i
if i would look like brad pitt i would
be an actor too
uh right but when it comes to music
everybody's picked up an instrument and
sat there and tried to figure out how to
you know play
a guitar or violin or whatever and you
realize that it's hard
that you got to really work really hard
at learning how to do it and it doesn't
really
come that easy so i think that the we
also
put musicians on such a pedestal in our
in our society you know and and i think
that uh
so i think there's a certain amount of
resentment about that crossover thing
kevin bacon here on the rich eisen shown
uh this is my own
pop culture filled brain at work here
kevin
uh you mentioned harry connick jr if i'm
not mistaken
harry connick senior defeated jim
garrison the real jim garrison in real
life for
uh in in the city of new orleans
uh for uh i guess the the lead attorney
and garrison if i'm not mistaken was the
the guy who was prosecuting the case in
jfk
am i not mistaken did i just do a whole
six degrees with harry connick jr with
you kevin bacon did i just do that
that is a pretty wild six degrees i have
to tell you that
yes yeah again well sure uh jim garrison
was
was the kevin costner um uh speaking of
kevin's the kevin costner character is
in the movie
jfk i had no idea about harry connick
senior right
that that news to me so i just connected
super cool
yes i just connected harry connick jr
with you through jfk that i just did it
i just i don't know i feel like i just
hit the i just i feel like i just hit
the sting here
with you that was him that was super
impressive
why thank you i don't know if you're
aware you are joining me here kevin
bacon
uh on the 28th anniversary
of a few good men hitting theaters near
you are you aware of that i was
i was not aware of that uh but yes
wow amazing what was that
like the first time you got involved
with that film i know we've talked about
it before but never on an actual
anniversary of the date
uh i'd love to hear oh yeah what was
that it was a great
it was a great it was a great thing you
know uh rob ryder um
who i was a big fan of um i would say
that uh
spinal tap is pretty much my favorite
movie ever
he he came to me and
he actually um there was another
part that i was kind of more interested
in and
um my wife said don't be an idiot you
you got to play that character of jack
she she definitely steered me away it
was more of like there was another kind
of bad guy part that i that i was
more interested in which one was that
the key was it the key for several in
part
i guess it must have been the part that
kiefer did yeah um
and um and
so i i ended up playing doing jack um
and i was really glad that i did i think
she she was right about that you know
i'm i'm so often kind of drawn to darker
edgier things but uh but it was great
you know aaron sorkin's script
um just uh sang and
uh you know to be with tom and and to me
and and to be working with nicholson who
just was
such uh an influence on me you know i
was thinking the other guy the other day
that
to me in a lot of ways he was one of the
first actors
that had this kind of attitude where he
didn't really give
what you thought about him you know he
he was never really trying to be likable
when you look at things like five easy
pieces and
the last detail and an easy rider you
know he
he didn't he never tried to be uh
attractive or cute i mean you know like
in chinatown you know he's got a giant
bandage on his nose
you know probably 45 of the movie and
you know it's like that to me
was that lack of vanity and commitment
to
the individual roles is something that
i've always tried to
hold dear to uh my heart and watching
him do that speech time after time
uh during the during that shooting day
it was it was really
it was cool to be with jack now i know
again uh you've told the story before
but just uh
for the purposes of of retelling it in
the in this
space here jack did the scene
over and over again you were for his
shot but also on occasion for your
shot and also for everyone else's shot
and kevin [ __ ]
set in every now and then too i guess is
what he told us as well
yeah because because the deal is is that
you know you have to shoot in one
direction
right that's where all the lighting is
going so obviously with a with a scene
like that you want to shoot
uh him earlier in the day but there's a
wide one and there's a tighter one and
there's a tighter one
so he'd done the scene uh you know a lot
of times and just
you know knocked it out of the park
every single time and then we had to
turn the cameras around
and you had to do uh the coverage of me
reacting tom reacting to me reacting
kavriak you know all of us
um you know and he just kept delivering
it even though he was off
camera and i remember his his uniform
was getting kind of you know his
jacket was open at that point his hair
was messed up and stuff
because he wasn't you know on camera
anymore but but
he just was he just crushed it and i
thought to myself not only is he
a great actor but that kind of um
professionalism that kind of
uh uh generosity from one actor to your
your the rest of the cast is something
that i i i took to heart
and and it's interesting when you were
just telling kevin bacon here on the
show when you were just talking about
nicholson and his appearance right um
and i i remember when terms of
endearment came out
that he playing a middle-aged man with a
little bit of a pot belly was a shocker
to so many people because of who he was
in the 70s and how he
kind of began to trade on his his own
age and his aging was in itself
a remarkable performance i remember that
about that movie well he's yeah well he
is a he's a perfect example of the fact
that you know one of the things
if you if you're able to to do it right
as an actor um the fact that
you age can be a real bonus because you
get to play different than new things
and you get to play
you get to walk in the shoes of a man
that's in a different part of his life
than he than he was when you were in
your 20s
and um he's really done that
you know gracefully and not been a you
know ashamed of it or afraid of it and i
agree with you in terms of endearment
there was a
there was a lot of um shock but for me
was just
admiration i was just wow you know he's
he just
he just does it so uh before i let you
go i asked this of you i seem
uh every time city on a hill are we are
we doing this again or what are we where
are we
i'm in the middle of this yeah in the
middle of the season yeah uh oh this is
great we got shut down
after our second episode in in march
um and uh we finally i guess about
a month or two ago got back up and
running and uh
we are we are shooting and um dog
willing we will
make it to the end of the season and uh
i'm really excited about this
this season i think the writing is
excellent we have a
some new cast members who are who were
great um
and you know aldous hodge is is here
with me
again and i and you know i love this
this character and they give me great
stuff to play so it's been a lot of fun
well i'll tell you what it certainly
definitely lends credence to your
statement earlier in this conversation
kevin bacon that you're drawn to dark
characters
my god uh yeah he's pretty dark oh my
gosh
you're plumbing the depths of your
character uh on this show
it's dynamite is tucker back too is he
back in the mix no tucker's not no
tucker tucker's not back this
this uh this season um unfortunately
because i'm i'm crazy about it about him
and uh
but but we're still in touch oh it's too
bad oh yeah well okay then uh if you
speak to him before i do
uh ask him how the red sox season went
uh ask him how that went
um and how is how is patser doing uh
go go for it do that for me will you do
that
because when he came here he came here
years ago because uh
you know this show was uh born on
directv and kingdom was a dynamite show
in which he dominated every scene in
that
in that show that he was in so he came
in here uh
and uh he took a video of him taking a
yankee hat
that i had in my um in my office and
uh putting it in the toilet that
actually happened
kevin which is not exciting
he's a pretty intense dude but i'm not
i'm not surprised about that right
exactly that's that's cold well you know
i can tell you if i can make a quick
sports reference
to uh to to it relates to play on
you know when i when the when the um
envy when i heard about the nba playing
in the bubble i thought to myself man
i'm
i don't know if i'm gonna like this you
know without a home court advantage with
with
you know little um zoom images up on the
wall and no
no no fans there and i found it i found
the season
really infectiously fun and i think the
reason was
that you see these men that are
so good at what they do and they love
doing it and the enthusiasm that
i felt from them to play
these games was it i just got completely
wrapped up in it in in a really pretty
fun and intense way and that is what i
see when i watch our show because
musicians uh spend their whole life like
like basketball players practicing and
getting good and you know getting their
chops up and
being able to uh play with each other
and and you and both of these are are
things that are
not so that much fun to do all by
yourself right and
when you look at um play on you'll see
that same kind of
uh infectious groove going on between
the between the players so
i hope people enjoy it well it's not
just that too kevin it's also playing in
front of a crowd
uh and and and and also uh
getting the energy from the crowd and
sending it back into the crowd and it's
sort of a symbiotic relationship that
you see with athletes in the crowd and
obviously musicians
with the crowd all you need to do is
just go to one bon jovi concert one
springsteen concert and you see that at
work
i could name obviously you know hundreds
of acts for that
and the fact that again that we saw when
we see these athletes still
and empty stadiums go through this and
it means just as much to them as when
there were a hundred thousand people in
the stands or what have you
it is infectious you do feel that in the
couch and you can forget the fact that
there is no fans in the stands and kind
of get lost in all of it which is what
we need to do
these days yeah you know yep absolutely
so you know
you know and uh so again i look forward
to uh play on celebrating the power of
music to make
change again that's tuesday 8 p.m
eastern with
eve and kevin bacon on cbs and cbs
all access and go check out
sixdegrees.org
for the non-profit organization um that
is going to be also at the center of all
this thank you for the call kevin i
truly appreciate our conversations
thank you it's always great to talk to
you rich right back at you you take care
that's kevin bacon at kevin bacon on
both twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here